good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching sky news breakfast now the hot
and
sunny bank holidays seeing people out
about enjoying their freedom
but how worried should we be about any
potential
third wave of coronavirus and is fully
unlocking in june
the best plan amid warnings that it may
not be
we'll ask government minister paul
scully who's on the program shortly
plus
[Applause]
we'll be joined by the actor and
renowned hard man ross kemp who's
showing his
soft aside to celebrate volunteers
who've shone
during the pandemic plus as japan
prepares to start vaccinating its
olympic athletes we'll talk to
samo farah about his hopes and fears for
tokyo
it's tuesday the 1st of june new hope
for families the baby who's become the
first patient in england to get a
potentially
life-saving drug with a 1.8 million
pound a dose price tag
on the nhs charged the daughter-in-law
of tory grande lord ashcroft to appear
in court
over the shooting of a police officer on
a caribbean island
what next after a bank holiday in the
sun how worried is the government about
a third wave
and will ministers put the brakes on a
june unlocking
a neighborhood under siege sky news
investigates as residents say they're
living in fear because of a housing
scheme
for troubled tenants some of them have
got mental health
uh some of them are alcoholics there was
a guy recently
who took an overdose and died in the
house upstairs as well
tennis controversy the world's highest
paid sports woman withdrawals from the
french open after being
fined for missing news conferences
following mental health concerns
a very good morning to you it's thought
to be the world's most
expensive drug now in a first a
five-month-old baby in england has been
given a potentially life-saving
treatment on the nhs which has a price
tag
of 1.79 million pounds per dose
the gene therapy has given new hope to
families who've children
have this particular spinal condition
let's talk to
aisha zahid who's in the newsroom for us
what can you tell us aisha
well as you said we know that
five-month-old arthur morgan is the
first nhs patient to receive this drug
therapy he received it last week three
weeks after
initially receiving his diagnosis and
his father said he broke
down after hearing that arthur would be
given the treatment
because it is a devastating condition
spinal muscular atrophy
is a rare genetic condition according to
scientific data
it affects around 10 000 babies
worldwide
and it's it includes symptoms including
progressive muscle weakness
loss of movement making it difficult for
babies to start sitting up start
crawling around
also difficulty breathing and it's a
condition that shortens life expectancy
to two years
so it's a really important potentially
life-saving drug
one expert told sky news how it works
inject it into the body and can get into
the cells in the body including the
motor nerves
and the motor nerves can then make the
protein or the protein can be made in
the motor nerves the smn
protein and that can prevent the motor
nerves from degenerating and dying
up until two years ago there was no
treatment for this condition in
particular so it's going to be
really great news for families affected
and hopefully provide a lifeline to baby
arthur
and many other children too okay aisha
thank you
the daughter-in-law of conservative
grandee lord ashcroft has been charged
with
manslaughter by negligence after a
police superintendent was shot dead in
belize
jasmine harton was being held following
the discovery of the body of henry
gemmat on the dock in san pedro on
friday
her lawyer told media outside the court
she'd been denied bail
and will be remanded in prison detective
detectives have previously said a single
gun shot was heard
and the gun involved belonged to mr
gemmat
miss hart and his partner of andrew
ashcroft son of michael ashcroft
former deputy chairman and major
financial backer
of the conservative party
now the government's under increasing
pressure to announce a delay in lifting
more coverage restrictions later this
month
some scientists are warning of a third
wave of covid with the india variant of
the virus spreading across the country
so these are the key developments this
morning and there are changes to some
travel arrangements
malta reopens today to fully vaccinated
british tourists
flights will resume tomorrow from moscow
to london
and heathrow terminal 3 is reopening
just to handle arrivals from the redless
countries
the variants are being renamed under a
new who
system the kent or uk variant is going
to be called alpha
the south african variant beta the
brazil variant
gamma and the india variant will be
called
delta more than 100 mps and peers
meanwhile are urging boris johnson
to promise that for every vaccine bought
by the uk
we should also donate a dose to lower
income countries
let's talk to small small business
minister paul scully who joins us now
good to see you this morning look
how concerned is government about this
third wave
well i think we've got to be absolutely
on our game making sure that we're
looking at the data
and carefully working it through every
day gives us richer data
but we're still encouraging everybody to
make sure they get their jab
and especially those people who have
already had their first vaccination to
go and get their second one that's why
we've
accelerated progress on that and we
we're still welding out the vaccine
vaccination pogo
at speed i mean professor gupta ravi
gupta
on one interview yesterday said the uk
is already at the beginning of a third
wave of infections
and at least three quarters of cases
were the variant identified
in india that's got to set off some real
alarm bells
hasn't it we're taking careful view on
what
where those um the uh any increase in
infections with the
indian variant are happening and that's
why we're looking at surge testing in
those areas and really making sure we're
getting on the front foot
but by accelerating the uh the
vaccination program making people get
those second jabs
that at the moment you look all the
tests are talking about the
the four tests that we have are looking
at
the number of cases but also
hospitalizations and those vaccinations
can help us break that cycle of people
having to go
to hospital if they get covered and
that's what's going to keep us on the
roadmap
yeah but 3 383 new cases
reported in the latest 24-hour period
now when you look at
that figure being just 2000 just a you
know a week or two ago
i mean the experts say the scientists
say that
you know this shows that these figures
are now rising
exponentially
if you bring to people together in any
setting then there is more chance of
people catching kovid
and so that's why we are still making
sure we remind
people that the vaccine that the virus
is still here that they still need to
adhere to putting their masks on
socially distancing
having good ventilation but again if
that jab is uh
they get asked to have their jab go and
have it because that's the only way
um we can actually get past this beat
the virus and get back to a sense of
normality because we've got to get out
forgive me forgive me a lot of people
would absolutely agree with that but
that's all going to go to pot come june
the 21st unless the government says
we're going to delay this by a few weeks
now what we're doing we're looking at
the data we're making sure that we can
use the latest information rather than
speculating now we've set the uh
the timetable that we'll make a decision
in a couple of weeks time we've only got
to wait a couple of weeks that we can
make the decision
based on that last data rather than
speculation yeah but
you you do acknowledge do you that there
is a at least the potential of a third
wave coming
there's the potential of an increase in
of of
um of the virus of transmission
and that's what we've got to be
absolutely alive to and that's why
we're encouraging people to get their
vaccination encouraging people to remind
them
to use masks to use social resistancing
and
have fresh air if they're in an indoor
setting as well to help
each other but of course we're using
we're looking at the data really really
carefully um
look our chief political correspondent
last night cited government sources
telling him
saying that the june 21st date of
complete unlocking
government sources saying that's 50 50
now do you agree with those sort of
figures
there's just the problem with
speculation is this affects people's
lives it affects people's business as
well
because we want to make sure that we can
protect jobs protect businesses
that's why we've increased the amount
that's going to apprentices um
so for companies to take on apprentices
to 3 000 pound for each apprentice they
take
but this is all part of the economy
making sure that
we're not making any decisions through
newspapers through speculations because
that's what companies
need certainty businesses need certainty
about their daily life need that stuff
they absolutely i mean business we talk
to businesses
big big and small on this program all
the time they absolutely want certainty
and of course they want to reopen
on june 21st fully particularly um
the the sort of entertainment and retail
sectors
but the problem is they'd be better off
having some certainty
now wouldn't they when a lot of
scientists
well-respected scientists that the
government says it's listening to
are saying we've got to push this back
now
they the businesses would benefit from
having a little bit more notice wouldn't
they
they absolutely would and we're trying
to give them as much notice as possible
but we're also trying to look at the
let the very latest data and yes there
has been an increase
in uh people with the virus but as i
said we're looking at what happens to
hospitalizations
to uh and the effects of course on the
from
the vaccination on the variance to see
how effective the vaccination is
i mean you you you talk about the
importance at this stage being getting
more and more people vaccinated
the problem is it's very difficult to do
logistically isn't it i mean there are
plenty people and and
i personally know some who've been
trying to get their vaccine cannot get
appointments or the appointments are
cancelled or they don't have the right
job available for their age group
they just can't get the vaccination at
the moment
well we're on target to make sure that
all adults can be
offered a vaccine by the end of july so
that's going great guns there will
always be
issues when you're trying to give
vaccinations that
we've had 62 jabs so far 62 million jabs
so far so
clearly we've got to make sure that we
can keep it as organized as possible
we've had some great stories coming back
just yesterday
um the the eleven thousand people that
were um
jabbed in twickenham younger people they
were saying about how they were moving
through the queues really carefully
there will always be situations though
and i'd advise people to make sure that
go back to the website
to look at the when the next appointment
is due that they can
take up their their jab look i don't
want to sound overly critical
because i mean this is a nightmare for
everyone involved and logistically
of course it's all a complete nightmare
but it
i just want you do sound a little bit
forgive me for saying so you sound a
little bit like you're fudging this
whole issue
over june 21st i know the prime minister
won't have told you exactly what he's
going to do but why can't we just get a
straight answer
saying you know perhaps from you saying
you know we are
there is talk of this third wave we are
really worried and this is all has to be
you know the june 21st at least has a
very real possibility of being put on
hold
why can't we hear that
this is what this is no this isn't fudge
what we've said we'll look at the data
we'll make a decision
by the 14th of of june as to what's
happening on the 21st
and clearly we we know the fact that uh
uh case numbers are going up we we do
want to make sure that we'll open only
open up
based on date not our data not those
dates as i say
and so we'll use the latest information
so this isn't fudge this is making sure
that we just don't speculate
that we use the latest information and
the most accurate information to make a
really
really important decision um we know
there's reports that a hundred mps and
peers are calling for
the prime minister to look at the global
issue of vaccination
as well more clearly and for every every
vaccine dose we bring into the country
we should be
sending one out or paying for one to be
to be sent
out to to those poorer countries
i mean in one hand it's it's difficult
when we haven't got everyone vaccinated
here but actually we
we are going to face a huge problem
aren't we unless we get the whole globe
sorted out here pretty quickly
yeah very much so you know we have we
won't be out of this until we can uh
get everyone vaccinated and that's why
uh the uk was one of the earliest
donors to kovacs setting up kovacs half
a billion pounds
uh were there which has vaccinated
people in 92
different countries around the world but
it's really important that we make sure
that we can keep progress not just in
the uk but across the world
yeah i mean so i mean what is the prime
minister going to do about this is he
going to be
pushing for this very heavily where at
the g7 meeting
well the g7 is a really important time
for people to come together and and
look at what we do across the world the
uk is one of the biggest
donors to gavi the uh the vaccination
body across the world and we will always
work together internationally
to make sure that we can uh get on top
of the pandemic through vaccinations
can i just ask you about the the
olympics um you know that not long till
till they're going
now that i mean that tokyo uh started
vaccinating their olympic athletes
whereas the
the rollout in the country as a whole
has been really really
poor only about 12 million out of 120
million people
have had any sort of vaccination at all
62 percent i think the figure is of
locals there so they don't want the
olympics to go ahead
what should we do
well again we'll use the we'll we'll use
the data the decision will be taken
that's not my decision so i
i haven't seen been part of that
discussion uh but clearly
we'll we'll make sure that we monitor
and see what's going on before we uh
send people over there
yeah well it's not a case of what's
going on in in japan though is it when
their figures are quite good they're
concerned about it all being brought in
and imported
into the country don't we have a
responsibility to say
perhaps well we're just not go we're not
going to put you at risk we'll stay at
home
well again those discussions will be
taking place it's not a discussion that
i'm
having i'm part of but uh but i'm sure
those discussions are taking place
okay minister good to talk to you thank
you
thanks well let's have a look at those
latest figures for you and there were 3
383 new cases in the last 24 hours just
one more death
that's only the second time since last
july the numbers dropped that low
40 million people have had their first
dose of a coveyed vaccine
i'll sort of come for you this morning
just after eight o'clock we'll speak to
the head of nighttime industries about
what a delay to unlocking could mean for
clubs and nightclubs
the 20 past nine will talk to ross kemp
who's swapping the more hostile
environments for
one hopefully more hospitable in aid of
pandemic volunteers
and as japan prepares to host the
delayed olympic games i'll talk to a
full-time olympic champion simo farah
who hopes to add to his medal collection
that's at 9 30.
now a skyny's investigation has
uncovered evidence that a type of
housing
supposed to help some of the most
vulnerable in society could be putting
them
and others at risk providers of exempt
accommodation can charge local
authorities inflated rents
in exchange for housing ex-offenders
drug addicts and others from troubled
backgrounds
but as our home editor jason farrell
reports from birmingham
it's led to at least one neighborhood
feeling like it's
under siege
violence vandalism addiction a leafy
suburb turned into a junk strewn
nightmare a birmingham neighborhood
which claims it's under siege
you name it we've seen it we've had
people
cars attacked on the road just on this
stretch here there was seven vehicles in
one night wing mirrors of cars being
attacked the hypodermic needles in the
tyres
the problem here and in other cities is
family homes being turned into what's
called exempt accommodation
which house high densities of troubled
tenants providers charge the council
inflated rates
and are supposed to provide the tenants
additional support
but we've found the systems flawed
majority of them are drug addicts
some of them have got mental health uh
some of them are alcoholics
there was a guy recently who took an
overdose and died in the house
upstairs as well so there is quite a lot
going on here
emma lives in an exempt property which
she currently has to herself
but recently shared
emma sent this video to her landlord
complaining her flatmates were taking
crack cocaine in the communal area
they sent a crack house and he said that
none of us are smoking it richmond
she says the man in this video died
three weeks later
and the requisite support was lacking i
kept complaining and said it's not wrong
i said what they're doing isn't right
and then about three weeks later that's
when the guy upstairs got found dead
and i turned around i said to the staff
here i said i told you
providers ox hill house say they did
offer support
and the resident died of a lung
condition but a sky news investigation
has found
a systemic problem with other providers
there are reports of domestic violence
victims being placed with men who have a
history of violence
this man spencer hobson was not risk
assessed by his provider in northampton
before he stabbed his flatmate to death
there was a similar case in birmingham
last year
it was these people either they come
from prison
they're uh you know have drug habits
all sorts of yeah you know the
unsociable sort of people that you don't
want here and so on and it's also become
very difficult because a lot of families
still got children here
and often you know walking down the
streets you'll see condoms you'll see
needles you'll see all sorts of things
and over supply of exempt homes means
families are getting stuck
in temporary properties the mother of
two toddlers living here for a year
didn't want to appear on camera you can
see the mold on the drawer
and all the clothes are smelling as well
windows are broken
it's damp and infested mouse is in the
drawer
oh god yeah let me see this mouse is
around it's cockroaches around because
i've still i'm storing everything in
these containers which are easy for me
now
the transient often overpopulated houses
turn streets into dumping grounds
in birmingham exempt accommodation has
doubled in 18 months
and the council says they can't stop
landlords some
linked to organized crime from funneling
problems
into their communities so we know that
there's a lot of um
providers and organizations that are
directly going
to places like probation services or
prisons or other places like that
outside of the city and asking them you
know we've got properties do you want to
actually
let you know let through us and these
are providers that we wouldn't
necessarily put people in ourselves as
the local local authority
so you can understand why some people on
some streets say it feels like we're
living in an open prison
absolutely and we've got absolute
empathy for them
birmingham and other councils want
greater powers to contain the problem
the ministry of housing told sky news
we're currently running extended pilots
in five areas
backed by 5.4 million pounds trialling
new approaches to crack down on the
small number of landlords
who provide inadequate support to
vulnerable people living in supported
housing
the housing regulator says it's
monitoring non-compliance in this sector
but many say the system is simply a mess
and needs urgently
changing jason farrell sky news
naomi osaka has withdrawn from the
french open
the world number two won her opening
match on sunday but said she didn't want
to do news conferences at roland garros
to protect her mental
health announcing her withdrawal on
social media the japanese player said
she'd suffered long bouts of depression
since winning her first grand slam title
in 2018
and she's had support from other players
i feel for naomi i feel like
i wish i could give her a hug because i
know what it's like like i said i've
been in those positions
everyone is different and everyone
handles things differently
so you know you just have to
let her handle it the way she wants to
in the best way that she thinks she can
a 14 year old boy has been stabbed to
death in birmingham it's thought it took
place on college road in king standing
with officers searching for up to seven
attackers who
later ran towards chester road the fall
says the area has been flooded with
officers
and that cctv inquiries are being
fast-tracked
a vigil has been held for a man who was
stabbed to death outside his flower
stall in islington
totally tony eastlake is said to have
worked the stall for almost
40 years and has been described as a
very special man
police are asking for anyone with
information or dash cam footage to come
forward
and help with inquiries
a little girl has been rescued by a
lifeboat crew after drifting out to sea
on a dinghy a 999 call was made to the
coast guards in the
village of conway county borough in
northeast wales
a volunteer crew scrambled and located
the child
thankfully she was i mean very clearly
frightened but
unhurt and they are all volunteers in
the rnli they do an amazing job
now there are growing calls for more
climate change topics to be taught in
schools
many young people want to know more
about the planet and
environmental issues and some teachers
say the current curriculum
is limiting laura bundock went to a
primary school in bristol that dedicates
six days a year to teaching its students
more
about changes to the environment the
expansion of bristol airport has been
rejected
planners have decided not to expand it
you won't find this kind of debate
in every school but cotton gardens
primary in bristol
is different they devote six whole days
a year
to teaching climate change this is a
serious
issue that that's going to really impact
on the future generations you need to
learn about
it because it's our planet that we live
on so you need to think more carefully
and take more serious actions about it
sometimes i do worry about
if this plan is going to be effective
and how much
longer we've got until it really really
starts getting real really worse and
terrible maybe they can't drive or maybe
they don't have a car
these lessons aren't mandatory but
teacher sam williams says they should be
you can have these conversations in a
safe in an age-appropriate way
and you can give the children the
knowledge to empower them
to understand about climate change and
then feel confident to take positive
action
they're taking action and making their
mark in birmingham
these older students are part of teach
the future
a campaign calling for more climate
change in the curriculum
really it should be weaved into every
single subject because whether you're a
builder or a banker farmer or pharmacist
you're going to be impacted by the
climate crisis so we should have the
education needed to build a resilient
society that has these knowledge skills
resources
they've taken their campaign to the
heart of government
the message more climate education
they don't tell you about the
socio-economic consequences of it
and that just leaves us in ignorance
about the actual
practical problems of climate change and
the solutions that we need to solve them
i definitely feel like a lot of the
young generation feel that
the people in power at the minute are
really letting them down some students
say
not knowing enough is creating eco
anxiety
in a statement the department for
education told us
it is vital that young people are taught
about climate change
which is why relevant topics are
included in the national curriculum
for both primary and secondary schools
teachers have the freedom to expand on
these areas
if they wish to do so what you'll need
to do
[Music]
but many feel the curriculum could and
should
go further to help nurture future
generations
and teach them how best to cope with the
climate crisis
laura bundock sky news birmingham
now when the sun came out people
certainly got out about and made the
most of it sun seekers headed to seaside
resorts
all over the country blackpool as you
can see
was particularly popular there's the
fabulous tower
best place to be brighton on the south
coast
with the pier and beaches were packed so
people do look
quite socially distanced which is good
it's got to be done you got to keep your
distance got to stay
sensible in all of this but how nice to
get out and about
in the weather in that weather or just
sit in your garden and enjoy it if
you've got one
of course the big question is is that
weather here to stay
joe please say yes well which bit are
you talking about the heat
or the sunshine oh you can have one
without the other
oh i think the sunshine because it
cheers it up a bit more doesn't it okay
all right well i might be able to
organize that uh as
always when we have very high
temperatures we do see a thundery
breakdown and that is on its way
yesterday 25.1 today 27 degrees celsius
tomorrow we could see 28 or 29 so we do
need things to cool down
but we've also got high pressure
building in at the weekend so a return
to calm settle conditions
with some sunshine let's take a look at
today's forecast
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so we're currently dominated by high
pressure but that's really over
scandinavia and it's moving its way
eastwards
and that's allowing this cloud and
patchy rain to work its way into western
parts of ireland
it's not actually getting very far it's
going to hover backwards and forwards
through the course of the day
so as we've seen in recent days any low
cloud mist and fog will burn off very
quickly today
lots more sunshine to come and it's
still warm sunshine temperatures
up to around 26 maybe even 27 degrees
celsius certainly
mid-20s for many it will feel a little
bit cooler on these eastern coasts not
because of the cloud this time but
because
we've got an onshore flow and then a
very nice end of the day
it stays mild overnight and also fine
it's tomorrow morning that we start to
see these heavy thundery showers making
their way into parts of the southwest
wales
and also the republic of ireland
torrential downpours
thunder lightning pushing their way
northwards through the course of the day
but ahead of that still warm and sunny
once again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast more on the coronavirus
situation is japan in japan as the
country
gears up for the olympics with a new
vaccination program
and yeah so my legs are basically just
really tight and it also affects
my right hand as well so i have to walk
and crutches everywhere
but most of the time i'm in a wheelchair
so when i was six years old i had an
unbelievable operation
in the united states which reduced the
spasticity in my muscles
and it has completely changed my life
and i just really want to give that
opportunity to somebody else
i think it's david set out to do this
two years ago when he wanted to join in
with the rest of us doing a
cross-country course
and when we heard him say it two years
ago we were like okay this is going to
take a lot of preparation but
david's he's definitely prepared last
year sadly it was cancelled due to
covert but yeah when we get over that
five kilometer mark it will be
he's already inspirational but he's
going to be even more inspirational he's
a living legend all the compliments he's
given to me i'm going to give straight
back to him
one of the kindest guys i've ever met
i'm just so loyal anytime
i've needed him to help me or do
ridiculous stuff for me that nobody else
would do he's been there
in the pouring rain at half 10 at night
when we can't see where we're going
he's there when we fallen over at the
top of the hill and rolled down
he's got me straight back up again so
yeah he's just the most
unbelievable bloke i think there's a
stigma that surrounds
disability and i think what david's
doing is he's proving that stigma wrong
and like you said it's it's not a nice
phrase
for a relationship for able-bodied and
disabled
and i think what david's david's doing
is proving that disability has no limits
you just because you are physically
disabled
doesn't mean that mentally and you
doesn't mean that you can't join in
with what other people can do and what
he i mean he looked at this as a
challenge but he's made it he's he's
he looked at it as it was impossible but
it's now a possibility and he's gonna
he's gonna destroy it later hopefully
[Music]
[Music]
now the small business minister has told
this program the government is
accelerating
the vaccination program because that
will help to keep the road map of
lifting lockdown in place
paul scully was speaking as a number of
experts warned a third wave of country
could hit the country
with some urging the government to delay
lifting the measures
by accelerating the uh the vaccination
program making people get those second
jabs
that at the moment you look all the
tests are talking about the
the four tests that we have are looking
at
the number of cases but also
hospitalizations and those vaccinations
can help us break that cycle of people
having to go
to hospital if they get covered and
that's what's going to keep us on the
roadmap
thought to our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen who's in westminster i
mean the problem here tomorrow seems to
be pretty clearly that the
the infection rates appear to be rising
exponentially at the moment
that's right stephen you've got really
competing pressures the government
message is
we're going to wait a couple of weeks
and look at the data and a bigger push
on vaccination they've announced a new
target now
for all on over 50s to have their second
jab
by the 21st of june that could help us
to have the opening up they want to do
on june the 21st but the problem and the
reason that scientists are warning we
could already be
in the early stages of a third wave and
need to be very alert
is because although the death rates are
very very low
we are looking at a rise in cases from
under 2000 a day at the start of may
to 3400 yesterday and rising
and if that is allowed to get out of
control as
while the nhs is also dealing with the
backlog of other procedures
they say things could get very worrying
again even though
we've got the vaccine shield if you like
this time which we didn't have
during the second and third lockdown so
scientists
going public now to say the government
should really consider a delay okay
tomorrow thank you
now japan is beginning vaccinating
athletes
ahead of next month's olympics that's
despite the continuing protests around
the country calling for the games to be
cancelled because of the coveted
outbreak let's talk to our asia
correspondent
tom cheshire i mean really is there a
lot of public concern tom
yeah a huge amount of public concern
just over a month and a half to the
games and 63 percent of the japanese
public according to one poll
don't want it to happen they're in the
midst of a second wave cases are coming
down but tokyo remains under a state of
emergency that's due to lift on june the
20th
but the idea of 90 000 people estimated
to come
over journalists athletes all sorts of
sponsors other staff
they see that as potentially triggering
a third wave and they don't want it to
happen
and japan has other factors against it
it's not vaccinating very many people
its regulators have been very
cautious in approving vactine's vaccine
sorry and only 12 million doses out of a
population of around 126 million
have been given so far now despite all
those concerns the international olympic
committee has said the games will happen
they can't be postponed again
and barring armageddon they will take
place
and the japanese government has
announced measures it's already banned
foreign spectators from coming to japan
for the games and is talking about
reducing the number of spectators in the
stadium and perhaps preventing them from
cheering or giving high-fives so far
though that is not doing much to
reassure a very skeptical japanese
public
okay tom thank you well let's talk to dr
nicholas rennick gp and vaccination
doctor
at a medical center in tokyo good to see
you this morning
are you concerned thank you very much
for having me um
yes certainly i i think uh the summary
that we've had so far
is an excellent um summary of the the
situation
on the ground at the moment um most
japanese people
are feeling that this is just not the
right time to be having a large
international event with an ongoing
state of emergency in tokyo and with
case numbers
starting to decline from the recent peak
but certainly
still much higher than comfortable um
and the issue of course is that our
population here
um still remains largely unprotected so
in tokyo for example
um only around 15 of the population over
65
have even had their first shot and less
than one percent have had a second shot
um vaccinations for those with high risk
medical conditions
um have not yet started at all let alone
vaccinations for the general population
and of course we're keeping in mind that
it generally is a five-week process
um for these vaccinations from the time
you start the vaccination to having full
immunity
um one shot and then three weeks later a
second shot with fisa
and then two weeks to build the full
immunity so june 18th would be the final
day
that you would need to start vaccination
to be fully vaccinated
so although the government has you know
made some promises that um the elderly
would all be vaccinated by the end of
july for example
um i think many of us are starting to
feel that when the games start
inevitably
a lot of high-risk patients are still
going to be unprotected
which is a situation that many in japan
feel very uncomfortable with um
including a lot of medical personnel
i mean in terms of of the restrictions
that are being put in place
uh for the olympics and obviously
foreign spectators not allowed in and
and presumably every everyone heading in
is going to have to be either vaccinated
or tested does that give you any degree
of confidence that
you know these tens of thousands of
incomers are
not gonna bring in um new cases or new
variants
so absolutely it is a herculean task to
try and keep
um so many tens of thousands of people
in this olympic bubble as they're
calling it um which we've seen with some
other smalling
uh smaller sporting events around the
world um
i think the the government has published
playbooks basically to sort of state the
kind of code of behavior
it expects for all people involved um
including the athletes so this
includes things like wearing face masks
at all times
um not visiting local restaurants bars
etc
um and basically it's just you know
you're you're there to compete you train
um you play and then afterwards you you
go to your hotel and read a nice book i
suppose
uh but trying to get people to avoid
doing the the mingling and things
um i guess the the big question of
course is um you know how
well is this kind of advice going to be
followed um
certainly i don't think the government
is in a position to
minutely police the actions of so many
tens of thousands of people
um and it really will um to a large
degree rely on the the individual
choices
made by the people coming to japan um
look
what about the vaccination program in
general
i mean i think i'm writing saying that
that that once
that they open up the to the
vaccinations of people under 65
it's going to be everyone eligible and
municipalities are going to have to
decide how to process
that themselves i mean that sounds a
little bit chaotic i mean it may not be
but it sounds like it could be it
certainly is going to be a big task and
we haven't had a lot of specifics about
how that program is going to be managed
um in terms of the the priority schedule
uh so we're largely uh
you know getting through the the medical
personnel at the moment including myself
um and then the second stage is the
elderly vaccinations
and then the third stage is going to be
those with high risk conditions
managing that is going to be quite a
challenge not the least because um
unlike many other countries japan
doesn't have very much
information on a national level of who
has what kind of medical conditions
so they're basically relying on
questionnaire forms uh to try and
basically say look you know if you have
any medical conditions and you're at
risk then just self-declare
um and and turn up on the vaccination
center
obviously that's that's quite a
difficult process um and there's there's
still some complications in there about
making sure that
the people who truly are at the highest
risk are going to get the first priority
look dr renick really good to talk to
you this morning thank you
thank you okay let's uh send our
attention to dr brian mccloskey who's
former director of global health at
public health england someone who played
a lead role
in planning for the london olympics good
to see you this morning i mean look you
understand
at least some of the pressures facing
tokyo and their olympic committee
at the moment would you be
more cautious though perhaps good
morning no i mean i think you have to i
can understand why people are concerned
but you have to see that
in the context of all the work that has
gone in the last year to protect the
games and to protect the population of
japan
and essentially you know there will
actually be very little contact between
the international visitors coming in
and the local population the athletes
will go to the village they'll travel to
their venues and back again
in their own transport they won't use
public transport so it will be a huge
separation
and then alongside that there's a huge
testing program so athletes will be
tested every day that
they're there they'll be tested twice
before they leave their home country
they'll be tested when they arrive at
the airport they'll be tested when they
get to the village and then we test it
every day after that
so there's huge safety measures going in
place i i just wonder if i mean there
will be people
watching who think well why risk it it's
a sporting event why risk it i mean we
know it's an important one
but nevertheless uh i mean i think you
know
from the athlete's point of view people
have been training you know for seven
eight nine years to get here
and it'd be hugely disappointing for
them to cancel it
but also actually the world needs to see
that there is an end to this pandemic
it's not there yet but it is in sight
and holding the game safely is one way
of showing that we know how to beat this
virus
and the world will be a better place
soon and i think that's very important
for people
yeah and they were absolutely an
important message but it's
it's very difficult when we look at the
realities i mean even here with
with the you know the cases rising
exponentially according to the experts
and and some saying we're already at the
start of a
of a third wave i mean from your
position when you're at uh
health england i mean that that's got to
cause real alarm bells here in the uk
hasn't it
yeah i think we do need to be very
cautious uh still and you know as we
said we need to stick to the data so
over the next two weeks
we need to look very carefully at how
the numbers are going now we are seeing
a rise in cases but we're not yet seeing
a rise in hospitalizations we're not
seeing a rise in deaths
and that could be the sign that the
vaccine is having the effect that we
wanted to have and that will allow us to
move forward
uh later in june but we will have to be
cautious and look at that data very
carefully
i mean in terms of i mean i know this is
just
your approach but you've obviously held
some very serious office with it within
the
the health industry here i mean would
would you be
more confident if we said let's put it
back two three weeks
um uh well we've got to think you know
we're looking currently at the indian
variant but the likelihood is that even
when that's gone away it will be another
variant you know
it'll be you know another uk variant a
russian variant a french very end of
vietnamese very
we have to at some point say we know how
to manage this the vaccines are more
effective than we thought they were
and we need to move on and get into a
better place so at some point we have to
agree to move ahead with that otherwise
we'll just be delaying and delaying and
delaying and that's not good for
anybody's psychological health never
mind economy
yeah no absolutely but i mean i guess
the argument would be
you know to at least get a higher
proportion of younger people
vaccinated i mean they're the people the
more you open up restrictions they're
more the people getting out about
heading to restaurants heading to
nightclubs all those sort of things
uh that uh that i'm way past now let me
tell you
um and it's about protecting them isn't
it
yes and i think that's what we have to
look very carefully over the next couple
of weeks and it may be that when we get
to the end of june
it's better to wait a week or two uh if
there'll be significant improvement in
the vaccination in that time
you know but if we're still seeing that
there's no change in the hospitalization
don't change the deaths
then i think it might be time to say no
we've broken that chain
now is the time when we can start to
relax a bit and start to see ourselves
getting back to normal
i mean can we because of your position
when you were
the head of global health i mean do you
can we ever say we've broken the chain
until
there has been significant progress in
in the poorer parts of the world where
whether the vaccines just aren't
available and the the logistics to
deliver them aren't available at the
moment
and that's very true and indeed there's
an argument which says the uk could do
itself more
good if you like by sharing its vaccine
with the rest of the world because if we
can reduce the rate of infection in
india and south america
you know around southeast asia and other
places that will reduce the likelihood
of more variants coming back to us
so it could be that giving vaccine to
other countries does more good for us
than than carrying on a vaccination
program here
and we need to think about sharing those
vaccines around the world dr mccloskey
good to talk to you this morning thank
you
thank you good morning
well still to come on sky news breakfast
i'm going to be finding out why those
some black or asian backgrounds
are apparently struggling to break into
the music
industry's hierarchy
[Music]
police have just made their first move
and they're bombing firing
again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded
five nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out
of wuhan after five days
stranded here this is deliverance we
help you
understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
hello my name is nadja frantier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the
west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
yesterday turned out to be the hottest
day of the year so far and today
temperatures
will be a degree or two higher with the
headline of around 27 degrees celsius
for central southern england plenty of
sunshine to come
a few showers potentially for the
western isles uh western parts of
mainland scotland
also for western parts of ireland and
still some
low cloud around northeastern coasts so
that
translates to pollen in terms of a
moderate count for much of england wales
and northern ireland but still a low
count for scotland
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now uk music says new figures show
people from black and asian backgrounds
really struggle to enter
top positions in the industry just six
point four percent of people
who are black or black british have
entered senior roles according to the
study
the results suggest the figure is even
lower for asian and asian british
professionals
at just four percent well the chair of
uk music's diversity task force is
amo tawa and he joins us now good to see
you but what are we talking about when
when we
talk about the the higher echelons of
the music industry
so we're talking about quite senior
executives within
trade bodies record labels and
publishing houses
and what we've what we've realized
and analyzed in terms of this data is
we've been really forensic around
just unpacking uh you know what
communities need what support
okay so so so what have you unfounded in
terms
in terms of of that unpacking and what
these different communities need to get
up in the industry
is it them that needs more support or
the industry that needs a shake-up
i think it's a bit of both i think for
the first time we can
actually uh really look at say for
instance
the black or black british
representation within the workforce and
say well what are those reasons that
entry level those communities are
quite high in terms of numbers but
they're just you know they're just
failing a little bit in terms of just
getting to the top and there's you know
there's two reasons one is
historical systemic issues within the
music industry but two
there needs to be better support and
recognition
ultimately if you look at all the global
data it makes fiscal
sense to have diverse communities and
different voices
in your music industry i mean in terms
of i mean what people
at home are going to think watching this
and if i
dare speak for you on this a lot of us
are going to think well
you know if we want to get into the
music industry if you want to get into
the top echelons
what do we how do you do it because we
do people like me
don't even know sort of what those jobs
are or what they entail
yeah i think it's about opening up
opportunities not just
to just the whole of london but the
whole of the uk
and uh you know access talent is
everywhere access isn't
so i think what we've got to do as a
sector is just open it up
we need we know there's work to be done
our 10-point plan at uk music
addresses some of those inequalities so
i think we're definitely up for the
challenge and there's been some major
changes since the last year it's been a
year uh
today is the anniversary of blackout
tuesday
and there's been some major major
inroads in terms of movements within not
just the trade bodies the record labels
and
and the music industry as a whole i mean
you'd sort of imagine wouldn't you that
the music industry was
you know more open to this sort of
things an area
that that was you know maybe at the
forefront of things
changing it clearly there seems to be
quite a difference between
what we see in terms of of performers
and the sort of artistic side of things
and what we see in terms of management
yeah there is i mean on stage it's very
diverse
and obviously it makes sense because
that's where people buy tickets and see
artists
behind the scenes we've got a little bit
of work to do but we know that
we as a uk economy ultimately are losing
by
not employing those diverse voices so uh
you know it
you know it's that old political saying
we're all in it together let's make some
moves and let's
let's be held accountable to those
actions i mean you're the boss of a
record company aren't you um
independently from from your your sort
of uh your chair of the diversity task
force at uk music
i mean how difficult was it for you to
to aim that high and then get there
well i was never supposed to work in
music industry i actually studied
engineering
uh so uh i don't know how i'm here but
uh
i think it's about passion it's about
skills
it's about being resilient and uh you
know you get those things
and some uh help from colleagues who
have helped us on the way so
you know sometimes there's a bit of luck
involved as well and in terms of
of ponce your company how what
difference does it make having
an asian british man at the at the helm
of that i mean does it does it bring a
different insight into how you view
you know potential deals potential new
artists all that sort of thing
i think uh having a diverse voice
or an individual who sits right at the
top uh
you have a position of difference one
you know you're born british two you
have an
asian or a black heritage so you you're
a mixture of
both communities and you have skills and
you have those nuances
and you can tap into uh other skills
that come from those communities as well
because it's quite natural so
absolutely and also for youngsters
coming up to
see themselves uh those diverse voices
those diverse individuals
at the most senior level is quite
uh inspirational for a young 18 year old
who's just
studied or music engineering uh to see
their peer or potential person that
looks like them yeah so it does help
yeah look am i really good to talk to
you this morning thanks very much
thank you okay let's have a look at the
weather for you this morning
his job
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there another warm sunny day in
prospect for much of the country
we saw 25.1 degrees celsius yesterday
today 27 tomorrow we could see 28 or 29
but it's not all plain sailing
we have got a little bit of cloud and
rain over western parts of ireland and
certainly overnight
tonight we'll see some heavy thundery
showers working their way up from the
southwest
devon cornwall wales later on into the
midlands and northern parts of england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come how worried
should we be about the third wave we'll
speak to a scientist who says
you should be concerned
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my name is fatima zanzilla the founder
of ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
[Music]
exchange if you recycle to get a tree
so
so
you